Long ago, it grew very cold.
Ice and snow covered the land.
Corn could not grow.
Glooskap, the leader of the people, had to do something.
Glooskap went far to the north.
Everything was white with snow.
He came to a house made of ice.
A giant named Winter lived there.
Winter invited Glooskap inside.
Winter began to tell stories.
Glooskap fell asleep under Winter's spell.
But Glooskap's bird woke him up.
"Go south, Glooskap"...
...said bird.
You will find a woman who can help you.
Glooskap went to the south.
He came to a land where it was warm and sunny.
Grass grew and flowers bloomed.
Glooskap saw Summer dancing in the field.
She had a crown of flowers in her hair.
Glooskap asked Summer to come north.
She came with him to Winter's house of ice.
Winter invited them in.
He began to tell stories again.
But Winter's spells did not work on Summer.
She began to sing her own spell.
Winter's house of ice began to melt.
"I am stronger than you."
...said Summer.
"You must leave this land"...
...she said.
Old Winter cried.
His tears became rivers of melted snow.
The corn grew.
The flowers bloomed again.
Summer spoke to Winter.
You will live in the north.
You may visit the other lands.
But in the spring, I will make you leave.
Since that day Winter rules for part of the year.
But every spring Summer drives him away.
Sometimes it seems like winter will never end.
But spring will always come.